- I'm very much looking
forward to this video
because today's topic is both quite juicy
but also highly educational.
And inspiration for today's topic,
was coming from a Harvard
business review article
that was reading, the article is called,
How Consultants Project Expertise
and Learn at the Same Time.
I will link the article
in the video description.
I do think it is quite insightful
and it pretty much asked the question,
are all consultants conman?
Are they sincere?
What tactics do they apply to potentially
create an impression from the
client that is not accurate?
And as an introduction to the topic,
I want to read out to you
one paragraph of the article.
"The challenge with effective
consulting is that it depends
on in-depth situational
knowledge that consultants
simply can't have when
they start an assignment.
What's more, they may not
yet be completely clear
on what the client -
who's paying top dollars
and expect results
immediately - really wants.
So consultants must rapidly and discreetly
gain knowledge of the client's business
while simultaneously giving an impression
of competence and self-confidence.
We call this challenge,
learning credibility tension."
And this is indeed a
challenge that you almost
always face as a consultant
if you start on a new project.
Because on the one hand,
the client expects you
to be super competent,
highly knowledgeable on
the topic from day one,
from the very first day you set forth
at the client's office.
But on the other hand, you might be young,
you might come fresh out of University.
Maybe you did a similar
project in the past,
for sure you do not know in detail,
the client's current processes.
So how can it be perceived
as credible and confident by the client,
if actually you are not.
If actually you might
need a couple of weeks,
a couple of months to get up to speed,
to really get all the knowledge
and learnings that you need to really come
to a great and valuable
recommendation for the client.
So this is the topic we're
going to talk about today.
So welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, I'm a
former strategy consultant
and I want to help you
to become successful
in the first years of your career.
Now, before we jump into this,
I know that this topic is
a little bit controversial.
And after watching this video, some of you
might really indeed think that
consulting is a conman job.
This is not really what I want
to say here with this video,
this is not my position.
And I also want to open
with a little disclaimer
that all the things that
I would talk about now
are to my knowledge,
not officially endorsed
by any large consulting firm,
for sure not by the employers
that I worked for in the past.
And these things are also not part
of any official training, curriculums,
of any of these large consulting firms
that I'm aware of.
This is a rather practical,
street-smartness,
type of knowledge type of tips
that you will pick up by
doing this job over time.
So let's start by putting ourselves
into the shoes of a consultant.
You're sitting at the client
in your first one or two weeks
of the project, and
you need to learn more.
You need to learn more
about the client's business,
the client's industry,
what exactly the problem
is that you need to solve,
how the client's
processes work, and so on.
But what can you do?
Of course you can just
blatantly ask the client.
What does this mean?
How does this work?
How is this supposed to go?
But if you do this,
if you ask these type of direct questions,
you will often get not so
nice answers from the clients.
They might say, "Well, this
is why I hired consultants,
for them to give me the answers.
I shouldn't train you.
You should know these things.
Why are we paying you so much money
if you're not even aware
of these basic things
of our business, of our
industry?" And so on.
And trust me that these are not
some theoretical considerations,
you'll hear things like that
all the time on projects,
these things happen quite frequently.
And indeed a partner I
worked with in the past
once taught me, "Well, Heinrich,
consulting is like close quarter combat.
You really need to be careful,
need to watch every step
behind every corner, behind every door,
there might be danger, be careful."
So it might be fair to
argue that as a consultant,
often you need to fake it till you make it
in the first week, so in the first months,
you somehow need to
pretend to be knowledgeable
to be an expert, until you really build up
that knowledge over time.
And this is now where the
juicy part of this video begins
because now I want to share
four of these sneaky tactics
that you could employ as a consultant
to create exactly this impression.
And again, I do not say
that every consultant
is using techniques like this,
and also do not necessarily
endorse to behave in this way.
But let just say the tactics like this
can be quite helpful
in certain situations.
And the first tactic
is to leverage the fact
that you as a consultant
have an opportunity
that many other employees
of the company do not have.
And this is that you,
as part of the project,
will very often be able to talk
to lots of different people
at the client, from lots
of different departments.
And by that you will
collect lots of information
that probably many employees
will not be able to have,
if they just work on one specific task
and one specific department
for their whole career.
So often by talking to one client,
you will pick up some industry trends,
some certain specific information
on what is going on in the company,
that probably another client of yours,
and another employee of the
company, is not really aware of.
So the next time you then
talk to this other person
at the client, you can
then selectively share some
of the information that you
got from the first client.
And by that, because this other client
might not be aware of that,
he or she will then often
perceive you as very competent,
very well-informed, that
you really know your things,
if you tell him information
about their company
that even they do not know.
And indeed, there's this
sarcastic saying that
"Consultant just borrow your
watch to tell you the time."
And while of course,
that over simplifies it,
I do think that there
is some truth to that
in the sense that this works
up to the highest levels.
Often after a project in the end
that if you already
present your final results
to the board, to the C level,
in your recommendation
it will not be unusual.
That is some of the
recommendations that you make
will be ideas that you more
or less directly derived
from information that you
got from other people working
in the organization, from
people really working
in the machine room, that just
shared some ideas with you
on what the company
needs to do to improve.
And to not digress too far
from the topic of this video,
I do not want to debate
the merits of this.
I do think though, that there
is an argument to be made
that even if consultants do that,
there still can be a significant value add
in the way that consultants do this.
But again, let's maybe part
this for another video.
The second sneaky tactic that
I want to talk about today
is just how you frame your information,
and specifically to frame
information that you have
as your very own experiences.
So let's imagine that you
indeed do some research
on the client, on the industry,
before you start the project
and you may be read a book
or report about specific things,
maybe you even talk to some experts,
some other people, some senior partners.
So you do know some things about the topic
that now you need to work on.
But of course the problem here is
if you're having a debate with a client,
and you want to share some
pieces of information,
and you just say, "Oh yeah,
I read this in a book"
or "I read this in a report."
Of course this will often
not be very convincing.
This is will not really portray you
as a big expert on a certain topic.
So instead you can frame
this as your own experiences,
you can say, "Oh yes, last
time I worked on this,
this is how we did it."
You can say, "From my experience,
this is how this is handled."
"This is how you usually this works."
"This is what other
companies in this field do."
And this frames you as
not only being book-smart,
it's not only being a student
who read about a certain
topic in the past,
but as being a professional,
as being an expert who has done
similar things in the past,
who has worked on these specific topics,
on prior engagement, on
prior jobs, or whatever.
My third little sneaky tactic
is on how to frame questions.
And actually this I picked up
in one of my very first internships.
I was working with a project lead
and she always seemed super confident.
She always seemed like she
really would know her things.
So one day I just asked her as an intern,
"How do you do this?
You always seem so confident.
No, clearly these topics need to be new
to you at least to some extent as way."
So I asked her, "How do you do this?"
And she indeed shared one little tactic
with me that I really found helpful
and frankly also applied
several times myself
then afterwards.
And she told me,
whenever a client uses a term
that you do not understand
or say something that is
not really clear to you,
instead of asking, what does this mean?
What does this term mean?
Instead of asking this,
because these questions of course
potentially make you look ignorant.
Instead, rather ask what
do you mean with this term?
What does this mean to you?
What exactly do you mean if you say this?
Because what this implies
is that not only you
understand the general meaning
of what this person was talking about,
but even have this higher
more abstract knowledge
that you are aware that not
everybody in every company
is using this term in the very same way.
So now you want to know
specifically how this client
and this company is using this.
So you completely turn around the frame
from you have no idea at all
about what this person was talking about,
to you really completely
understanding this,
but now you really want to understand
how exactly this is meant,
this is to be understood in this company,
for this client, for this person.
So the fourth tactic is
maybe the most sneaky one.
And I even asked myself
whether I should include it
but I want to be open
and transparent with you
because I do know that
some people do this,
but reflect on this for yourself
and only use at your own discretion.
And this tactic can help you
to be perceived as intelligent.
Of course, the client, when
he or she hires consultants,
especially when the client
hires MBB consultants,
everybody knows what the fees are
for these type of professionals.
They expect to work with
highly intelligent people.
And of course it might help you
if you are indeed perceived
to be intelligent.
But how can you signal
that you are intelligent?
And indeed, at least from my experience,
one of the strongest signals
that always have a very
strong effect is mental math.
If you're really good at mental math,
everybody would think that
you are highly intelligent.
Interestingly, this is
not only true for clients
but for your own team, for your partner,
your project lead, you work with this way.
And of course, ideally you
really are good with mental math.
If this is really easy to you,
and then you can indeed impress people
just by doing some crazy
calculations in your head.
So what do you do if actually
your mental math is really bad?
You're just not good at all of it.
So what you could do is when
you prepare for a meeting,
and when you know that you will present
for instance some parts of a document,
or maybe a whole document,
some pages of a PowerPoint presentation,
then already think about
are there some pages
with numbers on them and then potentially
you could do some little
calculations on your presentation,
that would seem quite impressive.
Because then what you can do is
that you can fake the mental math.
So before you walk into the meeting,
you think of a calculation,
you already calculate the result
with Excel or with the calculator.
And then you walk into the meeting,
you present the document
and then live, on the spot,
you pretend that you're
calculating something
saying, okay so you multiply this by this,
and then divide it by this,
then this is the number
that you would get.
So again, yes, this is
probably more than just sneaky.
So take responsibility
for your own actions
and decide whether you really
want to do this or not.
So now reflecting on these tactics
and I'll also want to make a clear
that these tactics are not
only relevant for consultants
but also for temporary
workers, for freelancers,
for other professional advisors.
These are just things that
are to some extent necessary
to bridge the so-called
learning credibility tension
that the article is describing.
To brush this tension,
from the very beginning,
you just need to be perceived as credible
if you want to succeed in your job.
But then at the same time
you also need the time
to get some learning from the client
to really get up to speed
and really understand
what this whole project is
all supposed to be about.
So I'd really love to hear
your perspective on this topic.
How do you see this,
did you already applied
similar strategies?
What is your experience with this?
As you know, I will do
my very best to answer
every single comment that you write.
And yes, every comment that
you do write also helps me
with the YouTube algorithm.
If you want to continue
your learning journey
with this channel, Firm Learning,
check out my other
video on how consultants
solve tough problems for their clients.
Really the video somewhere of our fear,
trust that it will be
worth to check it out.
And if you took any value
at all out of this video,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also hit the subscribe button
to stay up to date on all my content.
I release new videos
every single Saturday,
I also have an Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning
so follow me there to
see even more from me.
And indeed I also have
Firm Learning newsletter,
signup link in the video description.
And I want to end by saying
thank you to all the
members of this channel,
you're really making a big contribution
to the cause of this channel.
Thank you so much for your support.
So if you watch them till the end,
also let me know in the comments.
I very much appreciate that.
Thank you for your support.
Good weekend to all of you,
see you back next Saturday.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning,
all the best to you and bye-bye.